[Musique]
la presse quotidienne régionale et les
télévisions locales vous
présentent le club des
territoires et avec nous pour ce club
Pascal joanan bonjour merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous politologue directrice
générale de la Fondation Robert Schuman
et him el caroui bonjour merci d'être là
vous êtes consultant essayiste auteur de
ce livre nouveau monde arabe nouvelle
politique arabe de la france institut
mon c'est le rapport un rapport pardon à
l'Institut montagne merci également
d'être avec nous on va parler du
déplacement d'émanuel Macron au Proche
Orient Israël s Jordanie Jordanie Égypte
il a plaidé pour la relance du processus
de paix alors a-t-il trouvé une position
équilibrée la voix de la France
peut-elle porter vous nous direz ce que
vous en pensez d'autant audrai on le
verra avec vous que l'Union européenne
est loin de parler d'une seule voix oui
l'Union européenne qui recherche l'Union
justement à propos de la situation au
Proche Orient voilà pour le programme de
ce club on démarre tout de suite
Emmanuel Macron qui a donc fait une
tournée de de jours au Proche Orient il
a rencontré les dirigeants israéliens
palestinien il était hier au Ker et en
Jordanie son objectif relancer le
processus de paix résumé de ces deux
jours de déplacement avec Nicolas fleur
des TS israéliens pénètrent à
l'intérieur de la bande de Gaza cette
nuit un raide ciblé première brève
incursion au sol de tsal qui prépare
toujours son offensive terrestre c'est
donc d'abord pour éviter l'escalade
qu'Emmanuel Macron s'est rendu au Proche
Orient devant le Premier ministre
israélien d'abord il surprend en
proposant d'élargir la coalition contre
daesh à la lutte contre le Hamas je
propose à nos partenaires internationaux
je l'ai évoqué avec vous ce matin que
nous puissions bâtir une coalition
régionale et internationale pour lutter
contre les groupes terroristes qui nous
menacent tous face à une communauté
internationale pour le moins
circonspecte il écarte très vite l'idée
d'une intervention militaire française à
Gaza lors de sa rencontre avec Mahmoud
Abbas quelques heures plus tard en
6jordanie il appelle à protéger les
civils palestiniens nous vous exhortons
vous président Emmanuel Macron et les
pays membres du Conseil de sécurité de
l'ONU à faire cesser cette agression
contre notre peuple hier en Jordanie
accueil plus réservé certains états
dénoncent l'indifférence des pays
occidentaux devant la catastrophe
humanitaire à Gaza Emmanuel Macron
l'assure la France n'a pas de double
standard quant au respect du droit
international comment éviter
l'embrasement alors qu'Israël ne fait
que rappeler l'imminence de son
offensive le président égyptien lance un
nouvel appel c'est un point très
important que nous avons évoqué comment
faire pour éviter une invasion terrestre
de Gaza car une telle opération fera un
grand nombre de victimes civiles dans
l'enclave palestinienne où l'aide arrive
au comptegoutte la situation humanitaire
est de plus en plus critique un navire
hôpital militaire français doit arriver
aujourd'hui à Gaza Pascal Joan on a vu
Emmanuel Macron faire cette tournée
rencontrer plusieurs dirigeants pour
obtenir tenter d'obtenir la relance du
processus de paix il a réussi sa tournée
le chef de l'État ah ben canir le dira
c'est un peu tôt pour le pour prévoir ce
qui va se passer parce que tout est un
peu une cuisson lente en matière
de de politique au Oriant ce que je note
moi c'est qu'il a fait cette tournée qui
ne s'est pas limité à Israël comme la
plupart de ses prédécesseurs et qu'il a
réussi à faire le déplacement que Joe
Biden le président américain aurait
souhaité faire il y a 15 jours quand il
y é allé donc ça note quand même que la
France était capable de faire cette donc
il faut voir en effet ce qu'il a ce qui
s'est dit pendant ces ses entretiens il
va certainement faire état aujourd'hui
au Conseil européen et je suis sûr qu'il
va y avoir aussi des rapports qui vont
être faits avec les Américains qui sont
très présents dans la région pour voir
en effet comment on se coordonne donc on
parlait beaucoup d'influence de la
France alors elle est plus ce qu'elle
était il y a quelques années mais elle
existe encore elle n'est peut-être plus
suffisante à elle seule et c'est pour ça
que c'est intéressant de voir en effet
quel est les retombées de cette de cette
visite où en effet on a pu où le chef de
l'État français est le seul à avoir pu
sentretenir des directement avec les uns
et les autres pour voir quelle était la
solution la plus plausible immédiatement
sans sans pour autant renoncer à des
perspectives de long terme mais qui ne
peuvent pas être mises à l'agenda
maintenant him ALC oui Pasqual Joanin le
rappel Emmanuel Macron est le seul des
dirigeants à avoir parler à autant de
monde à avoir parlé aux Israéliens aux
Palestiniens avoir parlé aux pays arabes
est-ce que c'est tu parce qu'il a choisi
le bon moment pour y aller ou est-ce que
c'est parce que la France est la seule
en capacité aujourd'hui de parler à tout
le
monde je pense qu' la question du timing
est très importante Joe Biden aurait
parlé au au roi de Jordanie au président
égyptien s'il y avait pas eu le
bombardement de de
l'hôpital et à Marmoud Abbas
aussi pas sûr pas sûr mais pas sûr qu'il
qu'il en a eu envie même si je crois que
c'était prévu après est-ce que la France
est la seule la réponse et pardon je
vais être brutal et non la place de la
France aujourd'hui dans le débat au
proche- Orient est est devenue
malheureusement quasiment inexistant
c'est pas lié Emmanuel Macron depuis le
départ de Jacques Chirac la France n'a
plus de part de voix au Proche Orient
elle est perçue comme plus plus engagé
qu'avant moins avec une position moins
équilibrée qu'avant en faveur d'Israël
et puis surtout elle ne porte plus
aucune solution la solution à deux états
qu'on répète
depuis depuis 30 ans en fait on a on a
fêté au mois de septembre c'est passé
complètement sous les radars les 30 ans
du des accords de Washington cette
solution là plus personne n'y croit
parce que il n'y a plus personne ni en
Israël ni en Palestine pour la porter
donc venir en disant deux états vous
avez vu dans quel état est la région
donc cette solution n'existe pas et
Emmanuel Macron hier il a dit que la
solution à deux états n'était pas
caduque Cadu c'est le mot qu'avait
employé Yasser Arafat quand il est venu
en 89 à Paris où il a remis en cause la
charte de l'OLP et il a reconnu de cette
manière l'existence d'État d'Israël pas
employé de moadazard Emmanuel Macron on
imagine c'est un message qui est adressé
notamment au
palestinien c'est un message mais depuis
1995 l'assassinat de Rabine il n'y a
plus de parti qui qui porte cette cette
solution ni en Palestine c'est on voit
le poids qu'a pris le Hamas au-delà de
des des opérations militaires et
terroristes ni en Israël en Israël ce
sont les extrémistes qui ont gagné et
avec une stratégie et la stratégie ce
n'est pas de faire à la paix mais quand
quand vous dites que la solution à deux
états aujourd'hui elle n'est pas tenable
elle n'est pas tenable avec les
dirigeants actuels ou elle n'est pas
tenable même en changeant les dirigeants
elle est pas tenable parce qu'il y a pas
de partie prenante ça c'est une chose et
elle est pas tenable aujourd'hui sur le
terrain un état avec une petite
partie sur la sur la côte ouest qui
n'est pas reliée à la sjordanie qui
elle-même est truffée de colonie avec
une capitale qui est disputé euh sur le
plan je suis géographe de formation sur
le plan géographique sur le plan du
fonctionnement territorial économique ça
n'a aucun sens donc on s'agite comme des
cabriis sur deux états deux États mais
en fait elle n'existe pas cette solution
ni politiquement ni même pratiquement il
prêche un peu dans le désert du coup
Emmanuel Macron alors on peut pas
reprocher à des à des dirigeants
européens hein parce que je là je vais
mettre le ils sont tous sur la même
ligne en Europe hein alors peut-être
c'est de
l'aveuglement mais on peut pas reprocher
à une structure qui s'est bâti sur la
paix et notamment donc dans le pour ne
plus qu'il ait la l'affrontement entre
la France et l'Allemagne et on peut dire
que c'est quand même un un un des succès
de la de la création de l'Europe c'est
qu'en effet on ne s'est plus fait la
guerre entre nous hein même si
aujourd'hui il y a la guerre on y
reviendra sur le territoire européen et
il faut pas que le que le conflit qui a
lieu en ce moment au Proche Orient fasse
oublier celui qui est toujours existant
à nos frontières mais en effet on peut
pas reprocher à une structure qui qui
s'est bâti pour la paix pour justement
il y ait plus la guerre sur ce continent
et cetera de pas chercher en effet à
auprès des des interlocuteurs et des
acteurs de la région de de de rappeler
que c'est le fil conducteur ultime alors
qui n'est pas dont les conditions sont
pas réunies aujourd'hui et je j'en
conviens tout à fait mais de de de pas
dire que c'est à terme à très long terme
peut-être avec des acteurs qui
pourraient changer aussi parce que bon
il y a un moment où c'était un peu
possible là ça ne l''est plus compte
tenu de de de la situation actuelle mais
ça fait longtemps que ça n'était plus à
cause de de personnalité qui était aux
affaires de part et d'autrre de dire que
c'est quand même un peu le but que on
essaie de trouver les moyens d'apaiser
les relations pour éviter les conflits
qui sont réguliers répétitifs et qui
font beaucoup de victimes ouais est-ce
que c'est aussi parce que la communauté
internationale a un peu abandonné la
recherche de cette solution de états
qu'on en est là aujourd'hui
oui enfin c'est d'abord un un sujet
interne c'est pas la communauté
internationale qui fait la politique
d'Israël non c'est
l'terrière et qui aujourd'hui prener ce
dialogue est-ce qu'il y a une person une
personnalité un leader qui pourrait
contribuer à ce dialogue le dernier qui
aurait probablement pu le faire c'était
Ariel Charon qui s'était retiré de Gaza
et qui avait la légitimité militaire
pour faire la paix c'est souvent les
généraux qui font la paix souvenez-vous
irabine était avait été un grand
militaire israélien he euh aujourd'hui
et certaine manière la personnalité de
netanahou netaniahou n'aime pas la
guerre on le voit en ce moment
d'ailleurs il est critiqué par l'armée
parce qu'il hésite à envoir à Gaza à mon
avis il a raison mais le le la stratégie
depuis en fait quasiment 28 ans depuis
Rabine c'est pas la paix la stratégie
c'est la guerre la stratégie c'est le
fait accompli par la force la stratégie
on l'a vu c'est on enferme euh les les
Palestiniens à Gaza on mite le
territoire de de la sjordanie avec des
colonies on crée un système complètement
parallèle et on crée un état de faê
c'est ça la la stratégie avec derrière
des religieux je parle des israéliens
qui ont une volonté de conquête
territoriale de colonisation au nom
d'une vision biblique du du territoire
donc aujourd'hui on parle de paix mais
l'agenda pas depuis le 7 octobre
l'agenda depuis 1995 c'est la guerre
donc venir en disant euh deux états deux
états en fait ça n'a aucun sens ce sont
des éléments de langage pour les
dirigeants européens pour le président
américain mais en fait tout le monde a
abandonné justement on va parler des
dirigeants européens audre un Conseil
européen réunion des chefs d'État et de
gouvernement des pays- membres a lieu
aujourd'hui et demain et au menu
évidemment la situation proche au rien
oui notamment il y a plusieurs sujets
mais c'est notamment le sujet l'objectif
c'est d'avancer ensemble et d'adopter
des positions communes les 27 vont
notamment évoquer l'aide humanitaire à
Gaza une possible interruption
temporaire des combats et la situation
des otages mais ce conseil c'est aussi
l'occasion de rectifier le tir de parler
d'une seule voix parce qu'autant vous
dire que depuis 15 jours on ocile entre
division et cacophonie ça dépend alors
pour être tout à fait honnête après les
attentats du Hamas le 7 octobre les 27
ont adopté une position commune clair
mesuré voici le communiqué de presse
nous condamnons dans les termes les plus
sévères les attaques TER terroriste du
Hamas contre Israël nous affirmons le
droit d'Israël à se défendre dans le
respect du droit international et du
droit international humanitaire nous
sommes également engagés en faveur d'un
processus de paix fondé sur la solution
à deux états on en a parlé et donc fondé
sur le soutien à l'Autorité
palestinienne sauf que cette déclaration
que je viens de vous lire à mon avis pas
grand monde l'a entendu en tout cas elle
est passée sous les radars pourquoi
parce que quelques jours plus tôt
ourursoua van derlayen la présidente de
la Commission européenne s'était rendue
en Israël juste après les attentats et
elle a affirmé le soutien indéfectible
de de l'Union européenne à Israël et son
droit et même son devoir de se défendre
c'est tout elle n'a pas parlé du respect
du droit international pas un mot non
plus pour Gaza alors que les
bombardements avaient commencé mais pire
elle avait pas le droit de prononcer ses
mots parce qu'elle ne s'occupe pas de la
politique extérieure de l'Union
européenne et elle en avait pas non plus
le mandat de la part des États-membres
sauf qu'évidemment personne à
l'extérieur des institutions européennes
ne va relever qu'à la outre passassé son
rôle beaucoup ont ont vu la position de
l'Union européenne et ils ont plutôt
raison premier flou au niveau des
institutions mais c'est pas le seul he
non juste après les attentats du Hamas
le commissaire chargé de la politique du
voisinage de l'Union européenne a
annoncé l'arrêt intempestive de l'aide
au développement versé aux Palestiniens
on parle quand même d'un,2 milliards
d'euros sur 4 ans ce qui sert notamment
à payer les fonctionnaires Palestiniens
en Cisjordanie tler machine arrière dans
la foulée précision les aides ne seront
pas bloquées mais les contrôles seront
faits pour vérifier que rien ne va dans
les poches du Hamas des divisions encore
des divisions mais c'est pas fini les 27
ministres des Affaires étrangères n'ont
pas réussi à se mettre d'accord sur un
cesser le feu humanitaire c'est donc le
Conseil européen qui va devoir trancher
si possible en fait il y a presque
autant de positions d'état-membes
quelques exemples la République
d'Irlande soutient fermement la
Palestine par comparaison de situation
du fait de son conflit historique avec
l'Irlande du Nord Israël peut compter
sur le soutien indéfectible de la
Hongrie de Victor Orban de la République
tchè de Peter Fiala proche politiquement
ou encore de la Grèce et Chypre proche
militairement vous l'aurez compris c'est
un Conseil européen qui s'annonce
compliqué long pour vous donner une idée
la dernière réunion de crise sur le
Proche Orient a duré 7h sans pause avec
des discussions intenses sur le
positionnement des virgules des
communiqués le sujet est sensible
compliqué on l'a bien compris l'Union
européenne aujourd'hui c'est cacophonie
et division comme l'a dit
audre c'est c'est c'est parce que c'est
pas un état hein l'Union européenne il
faut comprendre c'est pas un état et ces
27 États qui se sont rassemblés depuis
1950 on est passé de 6 à à 2 il y a même
eu 28 membres pendant un moment donc la
politique étrangère ne fait pas partie
des compétences que les États ont donné
à l'Union européenne je réppelle
toujours que l'Union européenne ne fait
que ce que les États qui la constituent
veulent bien qu'elle fasse donc en effet
la politique étrangère ça reste du
domaine des états et donc c'est bien
pour ça que c'est au Conseil européens
vous avez parlé de nombreuses
initiatives qui ont eu lieu avec des
diplomates les diplomates préparent les
choses mais à un moment donné il faut
qu'il y ait une décision politique et
seul en effet les les chefs d'État et
gouvernement peuvent tenter de trouver
la de trouver une une solution est-ce
qu'elle sera suffisamment à la hauteur
c'est la question parce que quand on
revient vous avez bien précisé toutes
les difficultés qu'il y a et toutes les
différences d'approche qu'il y a entre
ceux qui sont et qui reconnaissent la
Palestine il y a neuf États qui
reconnaissent la Palestine dans dans
l'Union européenne il y a des gens qui
sont proches de la plus proche d'Israël
mais il y a quand même au moins une
ligne de une ligne commune qu'on peut cl
clairement appuyé comme ça c'est le
soutien à Israël dans ce qui s'est passé
le 7 octobre la condamnation de ce qu'a
fait le Hamas la libération des otages
hein et bien entendu la préservation
malgré la réposte qui a attendu d'Israël
des populations civiles et donc de ce
qu'on appelle l'humanitaire je rappelle
que l'Union européenne en tant que telle
est le premier partenaire commercial
d'Israël mais également le premier
pourvoyeur d'aide humanitaire en
Palestine tout simplement vous avez
rappelé le montant tout à l'heure ça ça
sert à la FO
cé les G qui vivent là puiss en effet ça
puisse le paiement des fonctionnaires
des des choses concernant les hôpitaux
la santé et cetera et puis la population
parce que le seul point d'entrée si on
ne le savait pas bah c'est c'est Rafa
c'est à la frontière égyptienne c'était
bien pour ça que le Président de la
République française en Égypte parce
qu'en effet il faut bien qu'en effet les
populations qui vivent là et qui ont
déjà de grandes ulé parce que le Hamas
est là et que il utilise un peu la
population et mais il faut bien qu'en
effet c'est ces victimes collatérales
potentiel ne souffr pas plus qu'il ne
souffre et donc là en effet l'Union
européenne a depuis longtemps une
politique d'aide humanitaire dans
beaucoup de régions du monde et dans
dans plusieurs pays de la région mais en
effet à la fois en étant commercialement
avec l'Israël et humanitairement avec la
Palestine un mot peut-être sur sur la
question de ces aides humanitaires quel
est votre avis vous
là-dessus il est il il est mitigé d'un
côté c'est absolument nécessaire on voit
le le drame humanitaire qui est en train
de se jouer sous nos yeux sous les yeux
du monde avec pas d'eau pas de
nourriture pas de fi les hôpitaux où il
y a plus
d'électricité puis de l'autre côté j'ai
un petit malaise parce que dire euh
apporter de l'aide humanitaire pour
qu'on puisse bombarder avec enf quel
sens ça si on veut faire de
l'humanitaire B en fait on arrête les
bombardements enfin on appelle au c le
feu c'est ça qui est humanitaire c'est
pas faire rentrer quelques médicaments
et permettre quelques opérations
supplment quand Emmanuel Macron envoie
un navire hôpital pour aider dans la la
bande de Gaza mais qu'appelle pas au
cess le feu pour vous c'est
contradictoire c'est très bien mais oui
en fait en vrai ça n'a pas beaucoup de
sens et si on se met de l'autre côté
c'est du côté des pays arabes pourquoi
le le roi de Jordan la reine de Jordanie
ont crié au double
standard parce que en fait je sais pas
si vous avez vu sur les réseaux
sociaux on est est dans un moment très
polarisé bon euh il y a des collages qui
sont faits avec les déclarations du
président de la République la présidence
de la Commission européenne sur des
bombardements qui ont été exécutés par
Vladimir Poutine sur des civils et des
hôpitaux où on condamne avec la plus
grande force et puis
euh bah il y a des bombardements sur des
civils le je mets de côté l'affaire de
l'hôpital de la semaine dernière et là
on dit Israël a le droit de se défendre
mais on va faire entrer un couloir
humanitaire franchement ça n'a aucun
sens
euh et je pense que les gens ils sont
très sensibles et à mon avis ce serait
plus simple de dire la vérité la vérité
c'est que israël veut punir le Hamas
considère que les civils doivent en
payer le prix à la fois parce que
probablement beaucoup d'Israéliens
penseent qu'ils sont complices et puis
de l'autre côté parce qu'ils se disent
qu'il a pas le choix et que il n'y a
qu'une réponse c'est la force et c'est
ça la position qu'il y a en Israël et
c'est ça la position de l'opinion
israélienne les Européens qui viennent
dire euh on vous soutien à fond et en
même temps euh bah on va vous aider à à
limiter un peu l'impact sur sur les les
victimes en vrai ça n'a ça n'a aucun
sens politique il ferait mieux de
soutenir complètement la stratégie
israélienne au moins ce serait clair
en faisant ça il s'ouvre effectivement à
l'accusation de de double standard
peut-être un élément à souligner vous
avez parlé l'Union européenne est le
premier partenaire commercial d'Israël
et notamment en matière de de gaz
l'Union européenne est intéressé par le
par le le gaz israélien depuis qu'elle
s'est passé du gaz et du pétrole russe
donc ça a aussi un intérêt finalement
dans la région ouais non mais il faut
pas le double standard en effet il faut
pas faut pas se faut pas être procrite
on peut pas dénoncer une situation dans
un dans un dans dans un théâtre et le
faire dans l'autre mais euh je crois que
tous les dirigeents qui sont allés quand
même en Israël ont bien compris mais ont
rappelé à à benamidou et c'est pour ça
qu'aujourd'hui peut-être il a pas encore
lancé l'opération c'est parce que si
jamais si jamais l'opération qu'il lance
euh n'éradiquait pas le Hamas mais avait
trop de victimes collatérales euh la la
la la la la l'opinion internationale et
le fait qu'aujourd'hui on se dise tous
voilà ils ont subi qu une agression et
cetera se retournerait contre eux et et
dirait mais voilà vous 'êtes pas capable
de cibler des gens alors en effet le
Hamas a joué un double jeu et
certainement a infiltré les endroits où
la population se situe je suis pas sûr
qu'il faut dire que tous les habitants
de Palestine et de de Gaza soient
complice du Hamas hein je pense qu'il
faut faire c'est pas ce que je dis hein
je pense que c'est ce que pensent
beaucoup de G voilà mais beaucoup de
gens mais donc c'est pour ça que euh on
lui a même le président américain lui a
dit attention à ce que vous allez faire
parce que si vous bombardez trop et on a
bien vu le le le ce qui s'était passé au
moment de cette hôpital mais si si on a
trop de victimes collatérales et que le
Hamas n'est pas éradiqué parce qu'on
s'aperçoit que ils ont des moyens de
contourner un peu les choses donc ça va
être quelque chose qui peut être long
mais mais sauf juste parce qu'Al joinin
que pour le moment les 27 ils ne
reprennent pas la demande des Nations
Unies de cesser le feu il ne prononce
pas le mot de de cesser le feu est-ce
que l'Europe l'Union européenne doit
clairement là pendant ces de jours
appeler auss le fa benah on va voir ce
qu'ils vont être capable de faire je
pense qu'il y a plein de points sur la
table qui sont en ce moment vous avez
rappelé une réunion qui avait été qui
avait rassemblé les les représentant
permanent de de de de l'Union européenne
il y a en effet desas des tasis sur la
table qui sont au standby parce que en
effet il faut qu'il y ait la décision
politique sur un certain nombre de
concepts et en effet le le le mot va
être important donc on sait que sur la
table aujourd'hui même rien que sur la
sur la sur le l'aide humanitaire on
parle parle de pause de fenêtres ENF il
y a toute une série de de de de de de
mots et on sait pas encore celui qui va
être accepté déjà si on arrive à une
position commune demain enfin dans la
nuit ça sera formidable Hakim elcaroui
est-ce que l'Europe l'Union européenne
détient une des clé de résolution du
conflit ou pas du tout quasiment pas
mais pas depuis le 7 octobre depuis bien
longtemps l'Europe finalement son rôle
c'était quoi c'était d'apporter de
l'aide humanitaire de construire à un
moment des infrastructures l'Europe avit
construire un aérop port un port à Gaza
qui ont été détruit par l'aviation
israélienne et puis l'Europe remet le
couvert à chaque à chaque épisode
guerrier
euh mais un un point quand même sur
quelle est à mon avis hein quelle est la
vraie stratégie qu'est-ce qu'est-ce que
l'Israélien sont en train de faire ils
sont en train d'essayer de rétablir
rétablir l'avantage et l'avantage
symbolique la politique israélienne
depuis bien longtemps est fondée sur la
dissuasion bon c'est pas la
dissuationion nucléaire même si Israël a
très probablement la bombe la dissuasion
du fort au faible avec ce qui s'est
passé le 7 octobre ce ce cette stratégie
a été remise en cause et donc Israël est
en train de remettre en place sa
stratégie de dissuasion du fort au
faible pour ça le gouvernement israélien
a un petit peu de temps c'est ce que
vous évoquez le temps il est donné par
l'opinion publique internationale et par
les gouvernements occidentaux un petit
peu de temps pour punir le Hamas les
Palestiniens la bande de Gaza on sait
pas très bien sachant que le Hamas il y
a une organisation politique et une
organisation militaire mais c'est plus
que ça aujourd'hui on peut détruire la
bande de Gaza tant qu'il restera des
habitants à Gaza il y aura il y aura
demain des membres du Hamas donc l'idée
on va détruire le Hamas comment on
détruitire l'État islamique ça marche
pas l'état islamique c'était une
organisation c'était une vraie
organisation d'une certaine manière le
Hamas c'est plus qu'une organisation les
Israéliens le savent parfaitement mais
ils veulent reconstituer leur capacité
de dissuasion après euh qu'est-ce qui va
se passer ils vont taper plus fort que
d'habitude parce que tous les 5 ans il y
a des frappes contre la bande de Gaza ça
va
probablement complètement déstructurer
les structures du Hamas et la la la la
la prochaine attaque du Hamas ça aura
pas lieu dans 3 ans ça aura lieu dans 5
ans ou dans 6 ans c'est la seule chose
que ça va changer mais là on est dans un
moment symbolique c'est la capacité de
dissuasion israélienne du fort au faible
c'est ça qu'ils sont en train de faire
un mot Pascal Joanin sur l'une des
phrases d'Emmanuel Macron lors de ce
déplacement quand il a parlé de
coalition anti Hamas en disant que la
coalition antidaesh devait être aussi
une coalition antihamas ça semble ne pas
avoir été
concerté avec d'autres États européens
il en sera question du coup lors de ce
sommet alors je suis pas sûr que en
effet céit comment ça pe pris pour
l'instant ça n'a pas pris ça n'a pas
pris et et je crois que Emmanuel Macron
on a parlé à ses différents
interlocuteurs et que je crois qu'il n'a
pas été convaincant
tout du moins que l'idée a était reprise
et et et et peut-être c'est une idée qui
reviendra plus tard mais pour l'instant
ça n'est pas du tout alors probablement
il en parlera aussi au Conseil européen
puisque je pense que comme c'est le
dernier à avoir été enfin le dernier
représentant européen avoir été sur le
sur le terrain il rappellera un petit
peu certaines choses euh c'est pas la
peine de de de de créer des l'heur on a
déjà suffisamment de mal à à à à à à à à
évoquer une position commune dans ce
territoire qui certes n'est pas voisin
immédiat mais avec lequel on a une
politique une politique de voisinage
dans lequel tous les acteurs sont sont
concernés qu'on a déjà eu en Syrie un
drame avec en effet des réfugiés et
cetera donc il il faut trouver les la la
bonne la la le bon levage mais le proche
orient ne sera pas le seul point du jour
de la de de de de la Réunion qui
commence tout à l'heure puisque on ne
doit pas oublier et ça il faut quand
même le rappeler que un conflit ne
chasse pas l'autre et que nous avons
toujours à nos portes la guerre en
Ukraine avec un Vladimir Poutine qui n'a
pas renoncé
à éradiquer la le les l'Ukraine tout de
moin de la remettre dans le giron
quiaccepte mal qu'elle soit tournée vers
les valeurs occidentales et donc là il
va falloir qu'on trouve aussi
le moyen d'expliquer que on ne se
désintéresse pas de ce qui se passe au
proche- Orient mais qu'il faut aussi
qu'on n'oublie pas que il y a sur sur la
table cette situation qui qui qui qui
est qui est vraiment à nos portes donc
on a le voisinage oriental et le
voisinage méridional qui font que si on
avait oublié un peu le voisinage
méridional ces derniers temps il revient
à nous et donc là on a deux fronts et
c'est un peu compliqué parce qu'en
matière de politique étrangère comme je
vous l'ai dit à chaque fois il faut que
ce soit les chefs d'État et de
gouvernement donc il y aura une réunion
en novemb cette réunion c'était une
réunion traditionnelle
R de l'ra l'raine ça sera pas cette
fois-ci puisque il y a un rapport de la
Commission européenne qui est chargé de
faire en effet tous les pays candidats
et ça sera en décembre puisquil y a un
nouveau Conseil européen régulier en
décembre là-dessus après j'ai une
dernière question pour vous sur un autre
sujet mais peut-être sur la question de
l'Ukraine et est-ce que Vladimir Poutine
finalement tire profite de cette
situation ah oui à coup sûr alors ça va
pas durer très longtemps mais d'abord
parce que le la tension internationale
est portée vers une autre zone ensuite
parce que il peut dire au sud global bah
regardez les Occidentaux de poids de
mesure il me condamne quand j'essaie moi
de récupérer des territoires je
considère légitimes et quand c'est les
Israéliens on leur donne un blancin donc
ça de ce point de vu là oui après ça va
pas durer ça va pas durer très longtemps
et et dernière question l'attaque du
Hamas elle est intervenue à un moment où
Israël se rapproché de certains pays
arabes est-ce qu'aujourd'hui ce
rapprochement est mort et est-ce que du
coup c'est une victoire pour le Ham
le rapprochement il est pas mort mais il
est mis en pause ça très clairement de
ce point de vuelà oui c'est une victoire
pour le Hamas et c'est surtout une
victoire pour l'Iran qui ne voulait pas
être être le le seul pays de la région
qui se retrouvait dans une relation
direct d'hostilité avec Israël même si
les pays du Golf depuis longtemps ne
sont plus dans cette relation mais ça
changa quelque chose si l'Arabie
Saoudite signer un accord avec Israël
merci merci à tous les deux on va avant
de se quitter regarder ce qu' a la une
de nos qutidiens régionaux avec
[Musique]
Audrey
et Audrey aujourd'hui la presse
régionale a bouclé sur la Grande Boucle
oui c'est le temps des réjouissances ce
matin en une pour les éditions de toutes
les communes traversées par le tour un
tour 2024 très original pour cause de
jeux olympiques le tracer évite la
Bretagne le nord et Paris les coureurs
slanceront de Florence en Italie pour
arriver à Nice et c'est la première fois
de l'histoire rappelle Nice Matin qui
titre à nous le tour alors dans le
désordre le sud-ouest dans la boucle
titre sud-ouest justement puisqu'il
passera notamment à poau et à gin pour
la montagne le Cantal est au sommet pour
le bien public le Grand Tour est en Côte
d'Or et enfin pour le républicain Laurin
amnville des dames et une petite reine
vous le voyez on ne lésine pas sur les
jeunes mot on est un peu chauvin du côté
de nos quotidiens mais on comprend le
tour c'est un événement c'est
l'événement cycliste même le plus
regardé au monde avec des retombées
évidentes pour l'économie et le tourisme
on continue dans le sport avec de
l'aviron pour une belle cause c'est en
Une de la Charente Libre la Ligue du
cancer propose des séances d'aviron
gratuites pour les patientes atteintes
du cancer du sein une activité bénéfique
physiquement et moralement ça permet de
retrouver de la souplesse dans les
épaules après une chimiothérapie ou des
opération d'éviter aussi les séances de
kinésithérapie je rappelle qu'on est
toujours au mois d'octobre le mois
consacré à la sensibilisation au
dépistage du cancer du sein alors
pensez-y on reste sur l'eau enfin
presque avec la Transat jadvabre en
réalité augmenter oui des expériences
immersives que Paris Normandie a testé
sur le site de la Transat des casques de
réalité virtuelle qui permettent
d'explorer un porte-coneneur de vivre un
départ de course au large ou une
expérience vertigéneuse en haut de la
capitainerie et puis si vous êtes plutôt
terreferme une idée de lecture en Une de
La Provence c'est la sortie du 40e
Astérix et de son compagnon Félix l'iris
blanc la Provence qui nous apprend que
René gosini aurait découvert sa vocation
durant son service militaire à auagne
l'univers d'Astérix a été nourri par les
vestiges Galor Romains d'arl exore quiil
a visité lors de ce service c'est
passionnant c'est à lire dans les pages
de la Provence merci audr merci beaucoup
akimel caroui on dit un mot de votre
rapport Nouveau Monde Arabe nouvelle
politique arabe de la France à
l'Institut montagne ouais bah l'idée
c'était que le monde arabe a
profondément changé et structurellement
dans ces masses démographiqu dans les
rapports entre les hommes et les femmes
notamment ce qui à mon avis explique le
le le sous-jacent de la de la monté de
l'islamisme l'islamisme d'une certaine
manière c'est une justification
idéologique et théologique du maintien
de la position des hommes avant la
transformation et face à cette
transformation l'idée c'était de dire il
faut absolument que la position de la
France change et qu'elle voit aussi ce
qui est important pour elle dans le
monde arabe c'est pas le proche orient
c'est le Maghreb merci beaucoup merci
d'être venu merci Pascal Joanin d'avoir
été notre invité on suivra évidemment ce
qui se passe du côté des 27 pendant ces
deux jours avec vous également audre
merci beaucoup merci à tous de nous
avoir suivi prochain rendez-ous à 18h
Thomas H sens public et nous on se
retrouve demain très bonne
journée